[Music]  kicking off he teased Kardashian ketchup  Kim Kardashian is cruising on  four-wheelers the 36 year old reality  star made her first public appearance  since her Paris robbery in Dubai on  Friday serving as a model for her makeup  artist Mario dead Ivana Vic's makeup  masterclass in between working Kim and  her pals took some time to have a little  fun in the desert posing for epic pics  and meeting an eagle pretty girl Kim's  soon-to-be sister-in-law blac Chyna  posted this adorable video of her  two-month-old daughter with Rob  Kardashian dream and her firstborn King  Cairo playing around with snapchat  filters it's not always easy to have a  bod like that we think not kendall  Jenner took to Instagram to flaunt her  toned abs Saturday in this  black-and-white teeny bikini she  captioned the pic chaos with a sea  [Music]  you